on a décidé lors du premier confinement
de transformer ce centre en 24 heures en
un sens de consultation pourquoi parce
qu'on était un aiguillon on avait
constaté que les urgences typiquement de
l'hôpital de poissy été totalement
débordée si on pouvait faciliter un
certain nombre de patients de passer ici
par se sentent qu'ils avaient été
transformées plutôt que d'aller aux
urgences et puis d'attendre d'attendre
et c'est ce qu'on a fait ça c'est
particulièrement bien fait
initiative d'un médecin de ville et
ensuite repris en septembre octobre avec
notre adjoint la santé monsieur dont
perd ou on fait un centre de dépistage
au pcr et il se trouve que neuf mois
après l'idée est naturellement venu de
dire ce centre de dépistage peut rester
sans de dépistage mais devenir aussi un
centre de vaccination un centre de
vaccination communal et c'est là où on a
été fort de propositions parce que c'est
pas simplement évidemment l'adjoint le
maire s'est aussi et vous le voyez ici
c'est une véritable fourmilière très
organisé on a une trentaine de personnes
qui vont se relayer tout au long de la
journée
du matin jusqu'au soir hier on a atteint
le chiffre de 126 vaccination à la
journée et pour ici c'est franchement
exceptionnel puisque on aime on a
démarré le 1er jour le 7 janvier avec le
25 personnes on est capable aujourd'hui
de monter à 126 donc ça c'est formidable
il ya un autre aspect qui est très
intéressant c'est que pour les
professionnels de santé nous commandons
le nombre de doses par rapport au nombre
de personnes qui sont inscrites à
l'avance pour les professionnels de
santé pour les personnels de plus de 75
ans je peux vous dire que je sais d'ores
et déjà avec le docteur denfer que au
cours des quatre prochaines semaines
nous aurons 612 donc 600 personnes
potentiellement vaccinable sur les
quatre prochaines semaines
ici sont possibles
reconvoquée un accueil des
professionnels de santé depuis de 50 ans
est aussi on accueille des patients de
faire des personnes de plus de 75 ans ou
alors des personnes qui ont 65 ans et
plus et qui ont des facteurs de
comorbidité et là en fait je dirais
administratif donc déjà on vérifie déjà
qu'ils ont bien pris rendez vous sur sur
ces médias et puis donc là il ya
quelqu'un qui est dédié donc à cette
tâche là ensuite on leur donne une fiche
en fait il va nous servir à nous pour
faire la consultation pré vaccinale donc
en fait vous tuer
au delà on le donne cette fiche là en
fait ils remplissent le brier l'autre
considérer les gens qui les ont pressés
d'en savoir si vos six hommes étaient en
contact avec des sujets comme une
politique savoir s'il ya des antécédents
d'allergie en particulier et puis on
leur demande aussi s'il ne se creuse pas
ce que l'on puisse utiliser les données
informatiques que
voilà donc en fait qu'ils remplissent à
y signe de cette folie après avec cette
fois là en fait on se dirige vers un
certain temps là on les installe dans
sept salles d'attentes ici on l'entend
au numéro en fait et après on va les
appeler à l'oreille si vous voyez qu'il
ya trois boxes en fait qu'ils sont pour
les médecins est donc là on va rassurer
la consultation auprès vaccinale donc là
en fait sur un médecin qu'elle entre des
questions en fonction de la finition
fonction d'eric la dalle affiche en fait
on doit peut-être approfondie à telle ou
telle question
on va leur demander s'il y a des
antécédents en particulier en
particulier tout ce qui concerne les
allergies on va leur demander aussi si
freins des médicaments qui pourraient
éventuellement contre indiquée ou en
tout cas dit milliers peut-être
l'efficacité de la vaccination
une fois que les passions enfin les
personnes sont été vus par les médecins
pour fait on va les diriger vers les
flammes hier pour donc là ici il ya des
différentes box il ya des infirmiers qui
sont dédiés à la préparation des vaccins
et des infirmières qui sont dédiés à
l'injection du vaccin
donc ça sera très rapidement donc on
invite la personne dans un box pour une
seule injection
une fois que ses filles ont une journée
une autre fiche en fait une fiche
administratif et cette personne va aller
donc aux services administratifs qui
sont un petit peu d'accord
on va rentrer quelques données de
manière à ce que ces données soient sur
un jeu dira un fichier national
une fois que ces données seront
enregistrées en fait la personne veut
attendre dans une salle qui est dédié de
manière à ce que on attend d'à peu près
30 minutes de manière à ce que si jamais
il ya des effets indésirables et c'est
un petit malaise malaise vagal
jusqu'à présent on n'a pas eu de
problème enfin bon tout peut arriver du
coup on attend ici à peu près 30 minutes
voilà également les invite aussi à
prendre le deuxième rendez vous parce
que vous voyez aujourd'hui c'est ça
c'est qu'on a le premier rendez vous
mais il faut avoir un deuxième rendez
vous pour les personnes de plus de 75
ans et 21 jours
donc il faut déjà organiser tout ça dans
ce qui n'est pas toujours facile et puis
pour les professions de santé ces 28
jours en sachant qu'on a qu'à un délit
un peu supplémentaire malgré tout nous
si vous voulez on est tributaire un
petit peu de la grèce en fait serrer ce
qui nous dit voilà cette semaine vous
aurez droit à tant de vaccins donc en
fait c'est sûr que forcément au final on
sera toujours tributaire on sera
toujours malheureusement lippi et main
par rapport à ce qu'on va nous donner
donc en fait s'il ya une pénurie au
niveau du trailer c'est vrai qu'ici en
bout de chaîne
forcément pour un moins vacciner donc ça
c'est clair donc forcément oui mais je
pense quand même que vous devriez y aura
une remontée d'autant qu'en plus il va y
avoir d'autres vaccins équivalent sur le
marché
donc en fait c'est un peu comme la
grille par la grippe ou vous avez une
dizaine de même plus de vaccins
potentiels
donc du coup je pense que ça à chaque
date même chose
non